SZYMON PERKOWSKI:
Greetings, everyone.
I'm Szymon Perkowski.
Today I'm excited to welcome
scientist, author, and speaker
Dr. Paul Zak.
In 2004, his lab
discovered that oxytocin,
AKA the moral molecule, allows
us to determine who to trust.
His work on oxytocin
and relationships
has earned him the
nickname "Dr. Love."
And his book, "The
Moral Molecule,
the Source of Love
and Prosperity"
was a finalist for the
Wellcome Trust book prize.
Dr. Zak was featured in a
Fast Company article related
to the role of social
networking in oxytocin release,
was named one of "Wired"
magazine's 10 Sexiest Geeks,
and his Ted Talk has gained
over a million views.
He is credited with the first
published use of the term
"neuroeconomics" and is the
founding director of the Center
of Neuroeconomic Studies at
Claremont Graduate University.
Today, he's going
to talk about how
to measure organizational
trust, policies
that will increase
trust, and how this
affects organization's goals.
Please join me in
welcoming Paul.
[APPLAUSE]
PAUL ZAK: Hi, everybody.
Welcome.
And everybody watching
in the live stream.
Very happy to be here.
And I want to be both useful
and slightly entertaining.
So that's my goal.
So I helped start this
field called neuroeconomics.
I'll tell you a
little about that.
We want to now
penetrate neuroscience
into management and culture.
So that's what we're going
to focus on primarily today.
I don't know any
human resources.
I know a lot of humans.
I like that you don't have--
HR is just the worst word ever.
So yes, people ops, much better.
Human development, better.
So let's talk about
how to design cultures
for high engagement
and high performance.
That's the stuff we've been
doing for five or six years,
and I will tell you about.
So here's an analogy.
You have friends, I presume.
Your friends invite
you for dinner.
Finish dinner, Eric
finished dinner
and he says, oh, it
was really great.
Here's $20 for the--
That would be weird, right?
Why would you pay
someone when they
invited you to do something
that was enjoyable presumably
for them and for you?
So once we understand work
as not something that is,
in econo-speak,
providing "dis-utility,"
something that can be actually
very enjoyable and fulfilling,
then why are we incentivizing
people with money for every
little task they do?
I think many tech companies,
Google in particular,
is an exception to this.
But still we're
thinking about, oh,
what this person really
wants is to somehow
get recognized with more money.
In which the process
of doing things often
is super interesting.
So when I started working in
neuroeconomics about 12 years
ago, before there
was a term for it,
I wanted to take a very
humble view and just ask,
instead of saying you're
irrational, or you're selfish.
Why not just measure
what your brain's doing
while you're making decisions.
Maybe they involve money.
Maybe they don't.
And then from that, build a
foundation for decision making
that's based on the
brain and not based
on some philosophical
tradition about stuff
is everything in
the world for me.
I like stuff, but there's
lots of other things
I like beside stuff.
So why am I so
focused on economics
on just getting more stuff?
Because it's measurable.
So for management, we
did the same thing.
Let's get rid of all the
stuff you learned at MBA
school or whatever.
And just start out with
thinking about people at work
as volunteers.
Essentially you
are all volunteers.
You're choosing to be here.
You have a lot of skills,
and you can take those skills
and go somewhere else with them.
So if I think about
creating a culture where
volunteers love to show up.
They're super engaged.
They're challenged.
They're recognized.
What kind of culture
would that be?
So that was my
starting point for what
I'm calling neuro-management.
How do we actually just
start from that idea?
Now, we have a lot of knowledge
in social neuroscience
about why people
voluntarily come together
to work on any kind of project.
So let's take that
knowledge and then try
to build a foundation using
neuroscience to understand
cultures and people who are
choosing to work together
on projects in cultures.
So that's where we're going.
Try to be very, very practical.
I guess my confession is
not an engineer, but son
of an engineer.
So we take a very engineering
approach to neuroscience.
We're going to run
experiments, then use
that data to create a solution.
And that solution could be, as
you'll see, could be a survey.
Could be a piece of software.
So we want to really make
this solution focused.
Otherwise it's interesting and
fun, but not valuable, I think.
So now we have a decision point.
I need to give you five
minutes of the background, some
of the experiments that have
proceeded all this work.
And either I can do
that for five minutes,
show you lots of
tables and graphs,
or we can have the buttery
voice of Morgan Freeman
tell us about it.
Me or Morgan?
Let's do Morgan, just for fun.
I don't know why.
So that was from
Morgan Freeman's show
"Through the Wormhole."
And obviously a little more
dramatic than the experiments
we run in the laboratory.
But that was preceded by a
dozen years of experiments
in which we designed
tasks that we thought
would induce the brain to make
oxytocin, this molecule that
makes us care about others.
And we've shown,
both in field studies
and in laboratory studies,
that, in fact, almost everybody
has the appropriate response.
And essentially, it's
one of the golden rule.
So I'm nice to Eric.
His brain makes oxytocin.
It motivates him to
reciprocate kind with kind.
Now, there's an anti-golden
rule and we can talk about that
some other time.
If you're bad to me, I'm
going to be really bad to you.
And that's also a
way we can play.
So we've done this
lots of places.
This is a picture of me with
my "tribe" in Papua New Guinea.
So I did an experiment
in the rain forests
of Papua New Guinea.
If you guys know about
Papua New Guinea,
you know there are
800 distinct languages
in this little volcanic island.
It's like going back
in the stone age.
No running water.
No electricity.
No bathrooms.
I mean, it's really,
really primitive.
And even these guys in an
ecologically valid setting
induce oxytocin release
when they engage in rituals.
So it seems to be
a human universal.
So as we began
studying this, we spent
a lot of time
understanding what inhibits
the release of oxytocin,
what promotes it,
so we could really understand
how this brain system allows
us to navigate through the sea
of strangers in which we live.
And one of the places that
we live with other strangers
is at work.
And so as we start
thinking about how
do we apply this to understand
why some organizations reach
high performance and others
don't perform very well at all.
Start thinking of a
simple model that we
could use in neuroscience
to understand that,
which I call the POP model.
So POP stands for people,
organization, and purpose.
So people is hiring.
So we could do a whole
other day on hiring.
Not going to talk
about it today.
So in short, you know
the right thing to do,
which is hire smart people
for the right cultural fit.
What we do want to talk
about is organization.
So I can take great
people, put them
in a really crappy
culture, and they're not
going to perform well.
Or I can have a great culture
and hire the wrong people.
They're not going
to perform well.
So this is really going
to focus on-- this talk--
on organization and on purpose.
And I'll come back to
purpose at the end.
So I want to push on to
two of those three levers
today, see what
we get out of it.
So here's the model we've
come from, from the dozen
years of studies.
And I should say, these
studies include field studies
at for profits.
So come in, take blood, measure
neurologic activity a variety
of ways from people at work.
And so not only does this
work in the laboratory,
it works in the field.
So we identified eight
classes of policies
that you can push on in
your organization that
can raise trust.
Somehow, magically, those
eight class of policies
have an easy to remember
acronym, oxytocin.
I don't know how that worked.
So if I push on these oxytocin
factors, one or more of them,
I'm going to get more trust.
The science predicts that
when I have trust combined
with a sense of
purpose, what I call
transcendent purpose-- I'll talk
about that in a minute-- then
I get more engagement at work
from these volunteer employees,
greater customer service.
And an outcome of that
is that I just dig it.
It's fun now.
There's still some
drag parts of work,
but by and large,
I love what we do.
I love the people I work with.
And I'm just knocking it out
of the park all the time.
So when I have high
performance, then I
generate this feedback
loop, which is,
now it's more fun come to work
because we're knocking it out
of the park a lot of the days.
Maybe not every day,
but a lot of times.
Man, we had home run yesterday.
That was awesome.
So how do I create that
environment in which,
again, even if I didn't pay
you, you still want to show up.
So I'm going to go through
each of those oxytocin
factors in some detail.
Not too much detail,
because I have an hour.
Give you an example
of a company that's
been doing this very well.
And at the end,
talk about how that
relates to outcome
measures based
on a sample of about
5,000 employees
from companies around the globe.
So here are the eight factors.
So once you have those factors,
how do you manage that?
Second confession of the talk.
As you guys know from that
nice video from Morgan Freeman,
I am a brilliant scientist.
I think of everything to study.
No.
I don't know what I'm doing
half the time, like you guys.
I'm just trying to
figure it out as I go.
So I actually had an
organization come to me
some years ago and
say, hey, we think
trust is really important.
Could you help us understand
trust in our organization?
And I said, oh, yeah.
I'll be happy to come.
I'll bring my needles and
my centrifuges and dry ice.
They're like, oh, no.
They said, is there some
of the way you can do that?
I start thinking, oh, yeah.
We know a lot about
this brain system
that allows us to trust
other people quite rapidly.
Oxytocin release happens
in a second or two
after you interact with somebody
if it's a positive interaction.
So we know a lot
about that system.
How do we turn that
down into a tool?
So we developed the
survey we O Factor
which allows us
to quantify trust
with an organization and
these eight classes of factors
that produce it.
That tool also allows us
to measure things like joy
at work.
So we're going to use that
tool to then seek to measure
what we want to manage.
That makes sense?
So let me go through
these again, briefly.
And we'll have plenty of
time for questions too.
So the first is ovation.
This meaning
recognizing excellence.
Someone in the room's
going to think, gosh,
day one in business
school at Stanford
and we talked about
recognizing people.
That's not new.
Oh, no.
Here's where the
neuroscience comes in.
Neuroscience has very
specific predictions
on how to get the most
out of recognition.
In particular, recognition
that is personal.
That is tangible.
That happens close in time when
the goal is met or exceeded,
and no more than a
week after happens.
That's public.
That's unexpected.
So you guys don't have this.
But these businesses that have
employee of the month parking
place.
OK, I guess.
But basically everyone
gets it, right?
Move it around.
But instead, for Eric
who I know loves coffee,
his team just
nailed this project.
They were working for
three months, killed it.
And then we come into our
all hands meeting on Monday
and I bring him a great gift
basket of really great coffee
and a nice mug.
Because I know him, right?
And I'm invested in him.
So what happens during
ovations is that not only do we
recognize the team
for doing well,
you have an opportunity
for a debrief.
So Eric, you guys
just killed it.
Tell us about the project.
What happened?
What went right?
What went wrong?
Say, oh, you know what?
We were working on this and we
thought we're going to do this,
but then we found out
that stuff didn't work.
So then we pivoted
and we did this.
And then three days
before it was done,
the servers crashed and then
we had to find the backups
and then Tori worked super late
and she worked til midnight
and she saved all
the data and then
we got the project done on time.
So we just got a
chance to do a debrief.
Not only on what
goes right, but what
happens when things go wrong.
So ovation is both recognizing
the individual and the team,
but also identifying
what do we do?
What's best practice?
Let's discover best practice.
It also creates aspirations.
So Barbara's team would
like to be recognized.
So when her project
comes up, yeah.
Saying, oh yeah,
that's pretty cool.
Everyone clapping for Eric's
team and it was great.
So you're building
up this culture
that says we recognize you.
We recognize that you
are working very hard.
We recognize you're putting
your heart and soul into this,
and we want to recognize
that it's valuable.
We recognize it as a
group that it's valuable.
And we want to use
the implications
of the neuroscience
to get the biggest
neurologic impact and therefore
the biggest behavioral impact.
And there's lots behind this
I'm not going to talk about,
but this sets up pathways in
the brain that essentially
make you crave that.
I want to be recognized.
I'm working hard.
Even the introverts, like me.
We want to be
recognized occasionally.
So yeah, you were great.
That's awesome.
Number two is expectation.
This is designing
challenges at work.
You guys know a lot about this.
Oh, by the way, I'm
putting the data up.
So the values here are how
much of each of these factors--
how much they explain
organizational trust.
All those factors
are not independent.
There's some overlap.
So they sum to more than
one because of that.
So expectation explains 70%
of organizational trust.
So again, from the science,
if I want to create challenges
at work, those challenges have
to enable what psychologists
call challenge stress.
I want to put you
in a situation where
you know what you need to do.
You know when it's
going to be over.
You have very clear goals.
The outcomes are concrete.
What I don't what
to do is move you
into a chronic stress state.
So chronic stress,
we know, inhibits
the release of oxytocin.
Puts you in survival mode.
Now I pull inward.
Just try to get through
the next 10 minutes.
I'm not worried about
organizing my team focus.
I want to get you on
the challenge stress,
like when I went skydiving.
If you guys have ever done
this, you are super focused,
particularly the first time.
The instructor says, you
need to do these three
things to get out of
the plane safely and get
in position so we don't
tumble out and you know--
OK.
I know those three things.
I'm saying it over and over.
OK.
Do this, arch your back, OK.
I got it.
So what you didn't
see is that I had
a graduate student who was also
a skydiving instructor with me.
And before we jumped, he
gave me cognitive tests
and I couldn't do them at all.
On the ground, I was cool.
And when I came back
down, I was fine.
So I was highly focused on task.
So when I design
challenges, these concrete,
difficult, but
achievable challenges,
your brain gets rid
of distractions.
You're focused on task.
I'm not watching cat videos.
I'm not answering
unimportant emails.
I have a reason
to come together.
So for this oxytocin
trust system to work,
I need a reason to marshal
those social resources.
So moderate stress,
as challenge stress
promotes release of oxytocin.
I need to depend on Simon.
He's part of my team.
I have no choice.
Our project's due in two weeks.
I need his input.
I got to engage with him.
And he's going to do an
important part of that.
If I can't engage with
him, the project's
not going to work out right.
So I have a real
incentive to do that.
Now, what happens when
I finish the project?
Go back to step one.
Now we have an ovation.
So from the neuroscience,
it's very important
that after I put you
under challenge stress
that you have a
refractory period.
So you probably know
this, but the brain
is very much like a muscle.
It gets fatigued.
The neurons actually
get fatigued.
So when you've been going,
going, going, what I want to do
is when you finish the
project on Friday, on Monday
not say, here's the next
giant thing you got to do.
Monday, let's celebrate.
Let's have cake.
Let's take half a day
off and go to-- what's
over here-- Great America.
Hang out.
I'm going to buy
you tickets to that.
Let's have this down period.
Catch up on email.
Go home at a regular time.
Then maybe Wednesday or
Thursday or next Monday,
I'm going to give you a big new
project to start working on.
So we need a little
bit of down time just
to figure out what we did.
Again, internally debrief.
Maybe debrief on paper.
Share that information.
Then move on to the
next big challenge.
So it can't just be challenge,
challenge, challenge.
Third component
is called yields.
Explains 57% of
organizational trust.
So this is something I think
Google does very well as well.
Crowd sourcing processes.
So you can think of
it as delegation.
So we have this project.
Here's what we want to do.
We have concrete goals.
I've set expectations,
I as a supervisor.
I want to recognize
you when you finish it.
I'm going to give
you the resources
you need to be successful.
But I don't want to
tell you how to do it.
I don't want to micromanage you.
If I micromanage you, I'm
going to inhibit innovation.
That's why you hire
people like you hire.
I want to allow you to have some
deviation from what's expected,
and I hope that's a
positive deviation.
Sometimes it's a negative.
And for that, we want
to put a floor, right?
We want to minimize the
bad outcomes and certainly
catastrophic losses.
But I want to allow for
positive deviations.
So when you practice
yield, there's
greater buy-in from
the people in the group
because now they
own the project.
Instead of me telling you how
to do it, me the supervisor,
you guys own it.
Figure it out.
You're smart.
You're working at Google.
You're super smart.
Here's the thing
we're trying to do.
Make it gorgeous.
Make it beautiful.
Here's what you need to finish.
Here's the deadline.
Go.
Go do it.
So again, very engaging.
A lot of organizations want
to micromanage because they
want to minimize mistakes.
So we've actually
worked recently
with hospitals that
will practice yield.
If you're trained--
training's really key here.
So I say train carefully
and delegate generously.
So I want to really carefully
train you in a hospital.
And then I actually want
my surgeon to be smart.
Don't just be a robot.
If you see something
more unusual, yeah.
Do a deviation.
Change that procedure
if it's going
to be a benefit to the patient.
Or if it could save time
for the organization,
or if it's improve outcomes.
So I want to allow
that kind of deviation.
But you have to
allow for mistakes.
So one way to do
this is-- I don't
know if you do this here-- but
you could celebrate mistakes.
You could have a,
yay, we screwed up
celebration or ovation.
Unless you are willing
to accept that people
are going to make
mistakes, which
is how you get innovation.
So I think even
though we often say,
like we tell kids, oh, everyone
learns from their mistakes,
honey.
It's OK.
Sometimes at work we say
but we don't really do it.
So think about some crazy ways
to celebrate the big fails.
If you're going to
get big wins, you're
going to get some big fails.
And again, you want to pull
the plug on those big fails,
not have catastrophic errors.
We don't want anybody to die.
But besides that, yeah,
we wasted a bunch of time
and we learned a bunch.
This is not how we do it.
That's valuable learning.
So let's celebrate that.
Next up is what I call transfer.
This is like yield on steroids.
So this is a role
in which instead
of saying I'm going to
assign work to Simon's group,
I want to ask what group
would like to do this project.
So this is really
enabling self management.
I should say as an
aside, I have a picture
here of Peter Drucker who is
my colleague, late colleague,
at Claremont for 10 years.
And the last article Peter
wrote for the "Harvard Business
Review" was called
"Managing Oneself."
And in that article he
basically argued in the mid '90s
that we are all our own brands.
If you are your own brand, why
am I assigning work to you?
Why don't I allow you
to manage yourself?
So if you can do this, you can
cut out layers of management.
Again, I think Google's got
a very flat organization.
It works quite well.
Many organizations do not.
We worked with a company
in the Central Valley
called Morning
Star Tomato, which
is one of the best run
companies you've never heard of.
It's the largest producer
of tomato products,
stewed tomatoes, steamed
tomato, tomato paste, in the US.
About half the US
market because they're
extraordinarily efficient.
About 1,500 employees.
There are no job titles.
And 80% of these are
seasonal, by the way.
So you're hired for the
picking processing season.
How can you get away
with no job titles?
You have to write essentially
a value proposition every year.
I want to join Barbara's group.
Here's how I'm going
to create value.
Valve Software up in
Seattle does this.
You have desks on wheels.
You join a group.
You say, look, I want
to work on your group.
You guys are doing cool
stuff, and I have these skills
I think I can contribute.
And they say, eh, maybe.
OK.
Show up.
We'll see if you're useful.
So just allow people
to self manage,
and then you can
have ultimate buy-in.
Now you own the project.
Now it's really yours.
So again, in some sense
this is a key sign of trust.
Instead of me now
saying, hey, we
got this project that's
coming in, you do it.
I'm actually allowing you
to choose when you do it.
So I run a 30 person lab.
So that's my little laboratory
to try all this out.
Sometimes what we
find is that people
don't want to be what we
call "primaries" on projects.
They don't want to pick
up and run that project.
So sometimes I have
to say, hey, Eric.
It's time.
You've been here a year.
You're trained.
I think you should be
primary on this project.
And we'll build a
team around you.
We'll give you the resources.
We'll make sure
you're successful.
And I as a supervisor need to
do constant feedback loops.
So the supervisor's role
is to do constant feedback.
The slowest you want to
do that is once a week.
After a week from the
brain's perspective,
it's like it's forever.
Never happened.
So constant feedback.
How's your project going.
Let's do a Monday
morning huddle.
Do you have the
resources you need?
Are you hitting your milestones?
What's going right?
What's going wrong?
What do you need from
me to be successful?
If I'm in that role, this
coaching role as supervisor,
then my job is to
make you look good.
And when you look
good, I look good.
But you've got buy-in
because you own this project.
You bid for this project.
You love this project.
So there's lots of literature
in psychology on what's
called locus of control.
Improves engagement, but also
things like health, happiness.
Next component I call openness.
This is a way to reduce
the amount of stress that
inhibits trust.
So if I'm thinking the guys
upstairs are doing stuff
I don't know about.
They're going to
sell off my division.
They're going to move
Google to Costa Rica.
If I have that kind of stress,
I'm not focused on task.
I'm not focused on meeting this
challenge that I need to meet.
So why not just
open everything up?
So I know you have a fairly
transparent culture here.
There are lots of
companies that have
gone to radical transparency
where salaries are public.
Performance data is public.
Everybody knows.
It's scary.
So I tried it in my lap.
So we do project based work.
On that project base,
people have hourly wages
and it's not so hard to
do some multiplication
and find out what
my annual salary is.
So I finally just
put it out there.
Here's what I do, the
stuff you guys don't see.
I got to travel, go to
Google, it's terrible.
I got to go to these places.
So I don't see my
little kids at home.
So this is why-- and I'm years
and years of doing this-- this
is why I get this salary.
So it allows us to
have that discussion.
Eric's been doing
this for seven years.
He has a different salary.
He has less experience.
He's doing different
set of jobs.
He doesn't have to travel.
So it actually opens up
that really interesting
conversation.
And pretty much everybody knew
what salaries were anyway.
In the world we live
in now, everything's
more or less transparent.
So I think there's
real opportunity
to be completely transparent
about what you're doing
and say look, we trust you guys.
So, for example,
Whole Foods does this.
They send out quarterly
profit and loss statements
to all of the employees.
They give them classes
on how to read them.
So you know how
your store's doing,
how the division you
work in is doing.
They really empower
division managers
to choose what
they want to stock,
choose what suppliers they use.
And so each department
within Whole Foods
is essentially a
little autonomous unit.
You got to hold together
and your store's
got to be cash positive
most of the time or else
you're out of
business and that's
a bad thing for everybody.
But you're going to run that
as your own little unit.
We're going to give
you lots of control
and then give you feedback
on how you doing and revenues
feedback.
There are lots of other
feedbacks as well.
Who was it recently, CEO
who posted I guess McKinsey
does this, where all the
senior people actually
just posted their 360s
so everyone can see them.
So you have to do 360s.
You want to see mine?
Yeah.
Let's put them out there.
So I have shortcomings?
Sure.
I'm a human.
So a lot of this really is
taking a very humble view.
I think sometimes when you're
a supervisor, when you're
a founder, when you're
a senior person,
there's a sense
that gosh, I have
to be omniscient
about everything
because I'm the boss.
And I have to know everything.
I think this approach
is very humble.
It says, look, these volunteer
employees who are here,
they're here because they want
to help your organization.
Just ask for help.
And being transparent is
a great way to do that.
Just ask for help
rather than demand it.
C is for caring.
So as you saw in
that video, oxytocin
facilitates appropriate
social behaviors
by increasing our
sense of empathy.
So when I have an understanding
of how people around me feel,
I'm a much more effective
social creature.
Again, sometimes at work we
think we should shut that off.
But that was a great guy.
I want to be friends with him.
We work together.
That's cool.
I can still be friends with him.
So why not just address that?
That's the natural thing
for human beings to do.
When you work
together, you're going
to be friends with a
bunch of those people.
It's OK.
You can be friends with them.
So an easy way to build
those social relationships
is to just articulate
the emotion you see.
So I come into work
and I see Barbara,
and I say-- instead of
saying, hi, Barbara?
How are you?
I'm fine.
Go to my desk.
I say, hi.
You look happy, sad, worried.
Then we can have a much
deeper conversation.
She can say, oh, you
know, I am feeling tired.
Well, can I help you?
Oh, well, my kids
have been sick.
My dog died or whatever.
Now we have a much
better conversation
because I've
actually articulated
the emotion I see in her.
And it's an easy way to build
this caring relationship.
Yeah, I do care about you.
If I didn't, why are showing
up, since you're a volunteer.
So it also means that you have
to allow your emotions to show.
Son of an engineer, not
always the easiest thing.
I'm with you guys.
But if you allow those
emotions to show,
then people will also
respond better to you.
So part of this is really
having the confidence,
having the trust in
the people around you
that I can actually share
with how I'm feeling.
So it I walk into work and
Barbara says, hey, gosh.
You look like you're
having a great day.
And I say, oh, whatever.
Have we had a good relationship?
No.
So here's a concrete example.
Woman in my lab a
year ago walks in.
She is walking on air.
I've known her for five
years, graduate student.
I say, oh-- her name's
Beth-- Beth, what happened?
Did you fall in love?
Like, you look great.
You're so happy.
She said, you know, I started
running three months ago.
I've lost 15 pounds.
I'm going to do my first
triathlon in two weeks.
I've never felt
better in my life.
Thank you for recognizing this.
And she has told me how many
times since then how important
that was to her.
That I actually just recognized
her as a human being, not as
a human resource.
Yeah, you work in the lab.
And you're kind of a
slave, because you're
a graduate student.
But I recognize that
you're a full human being.
You have a life outside of work.
You have emotions.
You have feelings,
and that's great.
And I should embrace
all those if I
want to be an
effective organization.
All right.
Two more.
I is for invest.
So it's very important
for the humans
to have a sense of growth.
So if you're using the
system I talked about so far,
then you may have
had the insight
that the annual performance
review is out the window.
Don't need it.
So we worked with the consulting
company in the Midwest that
was going through some crises.
And they started
using this system.
Got rid of the annual report.
At the town hall when
the CEO mentioned this,
people erupted in applause.
Everyone hates it.
Supervisors hate it,
employees hate it.
So I know you guys do much
more rapid performance review.
So if I'm giving you feedback
at least once a week,
clear goal celebrating
when you get wins.
Helping you out.
Even celebrating the
losses when it goes bad.
Hey, it went back.
Awesome.
We learned some stuff.
We're not going
to do that again.
So if I'm doing that, then
this delayed look back
at the last year or more of
what you did, it's useless.
And again, from a brain
perspective, doesn't matter.
So we created what we call
the whole person review which
is forward looking.
And because I'm
interested in you
as a human being, not
as a human resource,
that has three components.
One is professional growth.
I want to make sure that
you're growing professionally.
So key question
there would be am I
helping you get your next job?
Let's have that discussion.
Maybe your next
job's here at Google.
Maybe your next job
is somewhere else.
You want to start
your own company.
Let's have that discussion.
So maybe you want to spend
year working in marketing
so you can see how that works.
If that's what you
really dig and it's
going be still
engaging for you, yeah,
let's try to make that happen.
So one is professional growth.
Or what training do you need?
Or do you need to
go to conference?
Are you not networking
in the right way?
Let's help you facilitate
that because I want to have
the relationship with you.
So at lunch we talked
about Zooglers.
So you have a network of people
who were here and a lot of them
are pretty awesome, and
they can be a resource.
They're bringing work in
at their own companies.
They're somewhere else.
Or they come back.
Someone else trained
them in some other stuff
and now you can hire them back,
and they're trained for free.
How awesome is that?
You didn't pay for it.
So maintaining those
networks, very important.
So the second is
personal growth.
So is your family happy?
Are your kids happy?
Is this where you want to be?
Do you feel like
you're comfortable
in your environment?
Because I care about
you as a human being.
I want to build this
trusting environment.
Say, oh, no.
My spouse, she really wants
to live in New York and blah,
blah blah.
Well, let's have
that discussion.
As opposed to you coming into
my office pulling your hair out,
going, my wife's going to leave
me unless we move back east.
Let's have that
discussion in advance.
Where do you see
your family going?
Are you getting a good
life work life integration.
Not balance, because
there's no balance.
There's an integration.
You want to work at
home twice a week?
OK.
Let's try to make that happen.
For my student Beth, when
I did this review with her,
what she wanted
was I want to come
into work twice a week at
10 o'clock instead of 8
so I can run in the morning.
Boom.
Let's have someone else cover
the lab from 8 to 10 Tuesday--
can we do that?
Sure.
Because that's important to you.
And I'm invested in
you as a human being.
I've got to make sure
it's important for you.
And the third leg of
the whole person review
is what I call spiritual growth.
And that can mean whatever
it means for people
that you talk to.
It's not professional.
It's not your family.
Whatever else you care about.
What do you care about?
So it could be I need
time to meditate.
I want to take a class.
I want to volunteer at my
kids' school twice a week.
I'd like to get
involved in some-- I
want to take up rock climbing.
So I want to be able to
work half days on Fridays
so I can take this
rock climbing class.
Let's try to make that happen.
So I want to make sure that
you have this sense of growth.
When you have a sense of
growth, then what happens?
You're satisfied.
You feel like this
is a place for me.
This is a place I can
spend my whole career.
It's valuable to me.
Last component is natural.
So as I said earlier, sometimes,
particularly as supervisors,
we think we have
to know everything.
And it's really beautiful
to be imperfect.
In fact, one of the
key ways to initiate
the release of oxytocin
is just ask for help.
And you ask for help
when you need help.
So there's a finding in
psychology called the Pratfall
effect.
So if you stumble, people are
much more willing to help you.
You're seen as
much more likable.
So a classic example of this was
right after the Cuban Missile
Crisis in the 1960s.
All went south quickly.
And so Kennedy goes
on TV and he says,
I approved this
invasion of Cuba.
I thought it was a good thing.
Soviets are involved,
blah, blah, blah.
We blew it.
I blew it.
I'm the President.
The military advisers
gave me bad advice.
And I want to be a
better president.
So I'm going to try to
get better at this job.
I've only been doing
this for a year.
And I want your support.
And I want to be the best
leader for the United States.
His approval ratings went
up after the Bay of Pigs
because he owned the mistake.
Now, it's important that
you're seen as competent.
If you're stumbling and
you're seen as incompetent,
then it just hurts you.
But as long as
you're competent, you
can say, look, it didn't work
for-- this one didn't work out.
Wasn't so good.
So what?
We'll move on.
I'm OK with that.
So live up to your mistakes.
Own your mistakes.
Allow yourself to be vulnerable.
Southwest Airlines, which
we all fly in California,
see that a lot.
You see funny flight attendants.
Herb Kelleher, who's the
founder and CEO for many years
would toss the luggage with
the luggage handler people,
would hand out
drinks on the planes,
wear a funny monkey
suit to work one day.
It's about really just
being himself, having fun.
That's OK.
And it's very appealing.
And people loved him.
So if we take all
of those factors,
which again are not
statistically independent.
Regress them on
organizational trust,
we explain 100% of the
variation in trust.
So there are no other classes
of measurement factors
we need to worry about.
So what we're trying to do
is design this environment,
measure and
intervene in a series
of controlled
experiments-- and I'll
talk about that
in just a second--
so that you are so engaged.
And you're engaged not
only internally, but also
externally.
If I love what I do at
Google, I'm excited about it,
and I see an end user, am
I like, yeah, whatever.
I work at Google.
They're like, yeah.
It's a really cool
place to work.
It's challenging.
It's hard.
There's super crazy
brilliant people.
And we're trying to solve big
honking problems every day.
That's super engaging.
As opposed to, eh, whatever.
They pay me.
I show up.
I don't want that guy.
So I like what I call
the 3:00 AM employee.
Not all the time,
but occasionally, I
want to get an
email from someone
who works for me
at 3:00 AM going,
you know this problem
that we worked on
for like the last month
and we couldn't solve?
I found it.
I woke up in the
middle of the night.
I got the solution.
I don't want that every day,
because then you're just
a hyperactive crazy person.
But what I really
want is you to be
so engaged that you're doing
stuff that I can't pay you for.
You're doing it
because you love it.
You're doing it because
it's super engaging for you.
So that's the kind of
environment I want to have.
I want to create that
3:00 AM employee.
So interesting outcome
from the neuroscience
is that the pathway for trust
in the brain, this larger brain
circuit that we've
characterized as using oxytocin,
is overlapped strongly
with a brain circuit that
activates when we are helping
or caring for other people.
So besides Strucker, my
other management hero
is Edwards Deming.
And so Deming said at its core,
every organization's mission
is to improve lives.
So that's what I call
the transcendent purpose
of our organization.
So if employees understand
that transcendent purpose,
the neuroscience
suggests that there would
be this synergistic effect.
High trust plus high purpose
would produce this great sense
of joy, this happiness.
I just love it here.
So in fact, we find
that in the data, which
I'll show you in a second.
That picture is from Zappos.com.
That's called
"Monkey Row," which
is where Tony Hsieh
and his CEOs--
actually, that's their old
office outside-- now they're
in downtown Las Vegas.
That's the old office.
But it looks crazy.
It's weird.
People decorate
it in a funny way
and they're having a great time.
It's fun.
What are they doing?
They're selling
shoes and clothes.
But if you do it in
a way that really
makes people super happy, it's
fun, it's engaging, it's funky.
You can throw a Nerf
ball around and have fun.
Yeah, it's still
a super fun job.
It can be.
So you can reverse
engineer this process.
So for the people ops,
people dev people.
If you don't have
joy at work, then you
might investigate
some of these factors.
So again, from the
neuroscience we've
done-- which I'm glossing
over, but I'm happy to share--
and I have shared with
Barbara, some of the papers--
does suggest that places
you want to push on
are we're not communicating this
transcendent purpose very well.
Or our trust levels are low.
Or both.
So think of joy as, in
statistics language,
as a sufficient statistic for
a well functioning workplace.
If people are super
happy at work,
they're probably doing
things pretty well.
So here are outcome measures,
and we'll take some questions.
So if I look at the top quartile
of people using this O Factor
tool we developed to
measure organizational trust
and compare that to
the bottom quartile,
we find less chronic
stress, more energy,
greater productivity.
These are directly
measured, not self reported.
Directly measured.
We gave employees
tasks to do and just
measured with or
without, essentially,
a culture prime, how
productive they were.
More joy at work.
Greater sense of purpose.
That is, values alignment
with the organization.
I really love my
organization's mission.
Employee tension
much, much higher
in high stress organizations.
Greater job satisfaction.
Innovation we
measured with a task
we use in experiments,
field experiments,
where people have to solve
a difficult problem together
in a group that they've
never seen before.
And we can measure how
many steps they got through
in solving this hard problem.
So high trust employees
work better together.
They have these more
efficient social bonds.
They solve problems better.
Fewer sick days.
And here's the last thing that
was really exciting for me.
Not only are people
in high trust
replaces more productive,
more innovative, healthier.
They are more satisfied with
their lives outside of work.
So when you create
a great culture,
you're also creating great
parents, great citizens,
and a great society.
That's really, to me,
the triple bottom line.
Good for the employee,
good for the organization,
good for the world.
So we find this in-- that's
an old slide, by the way.
I didn't know I had the
Google slide in there.
Isn't that appropriate.
So we find this in, for example,
the best companies to work for.
The survey that Fortune's
done for about 25 years.
And recent analysis at the
Wharton School, University
of Pennsylvania showed
that these best companies
to work for in fact have
much higher stock returns.
So that great culture is in some
sense a competitive advantage.
It allows them to
generate higher profits
over a longer term.
So first of all, you're
increasing productivity.
But you're also reducing
things like hiring costs.
So it costs about 20% of
annual salary to hire somebody.
So increase retention--
assuming you're
hiring the right people--
then these people are not
only more productive, but you
don't have to hire as many.
Turn is lower.
So looks like there's actually
a real big payoff here.
So here's the recipe.
How do I use this?
Here's the take home
punchline slide.
Run controlled
management experiments.
Just like you run experiments on
the software, on the interface,
on the UX, just start out.
Clarify what objective
you want to push on.
I'm going to give you a concrete
example in just a moment.
Identify how you
measure the change.
How would I know if I'm
moving towards that objective?
Then identify an experiment
and tell people in the group,
we're going to try
this experiment.
We're going to intervene here,
and we'll see what happens.
Implement the innovation.
If it works, stick with it.
If it doesn't, go back
to the status quo.
Hey, we tried this.
It didn't work.
We thought it would be good.
You guys didn't like it.
We'll just go back to
what we did before.
No harm, no foul.
And then do it again.
So this very much
an [INAUDIBLE] role.
Kind of get continuous
improvement.
Little management
experiments all the time.
And I know you guys do
this all the time anyway.
But I'm trying to give you
a theoretical structure
underneath that.
It's really about
building a culture
in which social
relationships are paramount.
They're really,
really efficient.
So I think of trust
as a social lubricant.
When trust is high,
it's easy to get
things done because the
frictions are lower.
And it includes getting
things done at work.
It's just easier
when I trust people.
So I want to thoughtfully
design a culture for high trust
because I want to reduce
those frictions at work.
So here's an example.
We worked with a large-ish
insurance company,
whose name you would know.
And they had retention problems.
And their retention problems
were in a particular division.
And so we said, OK.
Let's work on that division.
So your problem
is high turnover.
And so when we did
the O Factor survey,
we found that the invest
number, of those eight factors,
invest was really low.
And you talked to the
employees and they'd say,
you know what, I got
hired here out of college.
I'm working in this division.
There's no career ladder.
No one's really mentoring me.
It's a burnout job, entry level.
I just leave.
I said, OK.
Let's put in programs so
that you have mentors.
You have a clear career ladder.
You have a career coach.
Let's hire some
people who are senior,
and their job is to coach you.
Where are you going?
What do you like?
Which division would
you like to move to?
How do I help you get your
next job within this company?
So really, really effective.
Communicate clearly the change.
Implement the change.
And in this company,
retention went way up.
People said, oh, yeah.
Now I get.
I'm starting here on the
phones, not super fun.
But if I do well here,
I'm learning this business
from the ground up
and I'll move on.
So super clear on
what we're doing.
Time for questions or comments?
I know I spoke super fast
and didn't take any breaths.
And that's just the way I am.
But I'd be happy
to take questions.
Do we need to use the mic, sir?
We do need to use the mic.
So thank you for
listening and I'm
hoping to be of service to
all my friends at Google.
It's my fourth trip, so super
happy to be here, you guys.
Thank you so much, and thank to
Barbara Usher who brought me in
and Simon who arranged my visit.
SZYMON PERKOWSKI: All right.
Let's give Paul a
round of applause.
PAUL ZAK: Oh, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SZYMON PERKOWSKI:
So at this time,
we'll take some questions
from the audience.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question about oxytocin.
PAUL ZAK: Yes, ma'am.
AUDIENCE: I'm wondering how
much the baseline levels differ
between individuals generally,
and if they are drastically
lower in people who
are, like, psychopaths
or maybe suffer from
forms of autism or--
PAUL ZAK: Great question.
And so the back story on
this, what started out
as basic science research did
spawn a lot of clinical trials
for things like autism,
schizophrenia, social anxiety,
depression.
We've work with
psychopaths in prisons.
So oxytocin, like many
other chemicals in the body,
is re-used.
So it functions
outside the brain
to facilitate uterine
contractions during birth,
milk letdown for breastfeeding.
But in the brain, it
functions much more
like a neurotransmitter,
that is, acute responses.
And so the secret on why it
really hadn't been studied
outside of reproduction is
no one figured out a way
to actually measure that acute
brain response, and we did.
And once we had this tool,
then you can go to town
and ask a lot of
questions with that tool.
And this was based
on animal research.
So I took the animal research,
turned it into human research,
which is not always trivial.
But once we had that, it worked.
So what we found is that
everybody makes oxytocin,
they just don't always
make it at the right times.
So if you're having a really
bad day, high levels of stress,
you inhibit oxytocin release.
If you had a very
adverse childhood,
abuse neglect history,
then the brain regions that
should have many oxytocin
receptors atrophy,
and then you don't get
this feel good effect
that we get when we interact
with people in a nice way.
In the psychopathic study,
this is research coming out
soon in a journal, we found that
all those guys make oxytocin.
So it's not the chronic level.
It's this acute response.
And that's the trick.
They don't get the acute
response in the right away.
And, in fact, they
make lots of oxytocin
because their receptors
are dysfunctional.
And what do they lack primarily?
Psychopaths lack empathy.
And that's exactly what
oxytocin increases most.
So oxytocin is an
innate moral compass.
I'm getting feedback when I
interact with the humans based
on their body language,
the way they treat me,
their expressions, on whether
my behavior was appropriate.
And once you've
been on the planet
for more than about
20 years, you've
figured out that I could get
Eric to help me with my project
by beating the crap
out of him, or I
could treat him really nice.
Eric, you're super smart, man.
Do you have time?
Do you have like half an hour
you can help me with this?
That's a much better
approach, right?
So anyway, it doesn't take
a genius to figure that out.
But the hard part
is taking this quote
"reproductive" hormone as
one of my colleagues said,
this female hormone, and
showing that we all release it.
And in the right
circumstances, it
guides us to the
appropriate social behavior.
So yeah, great science question.
Thank you.
SZYMON PERKOWSKI: OK.
There's another
question on the Dory.
PAUL ZAK: Yes.
SZYMON PERKOWSKI: "Do some
people need these factors
more than others?
It seems that some people
function better in workplaces
without many of these
features than other people do.
If so, do you have any thoughts
about the differences?"
PAUL ZAK: Yeah.
It's a great question.
This reminds me of your
former colleague Marissa Mayer
at Yahoo, having
everybody come into work.
So what if a loner and I
just like to be by myself,
and I don't need
the human so much.
I think to an extent,
Marissa was right.
We do want to have these
collisions in which I'm just
bumping into people.
From my time here
today, I understand
that you guys create
teams are very rapidly
and reform teams very rapidly.
So it's difficult
to trust someone
that I don't know much about.
Even though they work here.
They have to be kind of
OK because they work here.
How do I know that?
How do I build trust rapidly?
So that's what I
want to talk about.
And one way is to use these
factors in the micro scale.
So I can actually tell the
people in my group something
vulnerable about myself.
Something embarrassing.
Something difficult.
So I have students
do this in class.
So tell me something
really weird about yourself
so I can remember it.
First, I'll remember you better.
But something that's
not super flattering.
Something unusual.
So you can start with that.
Just start small.
Before we talk about
work, let's just about us.
We're going to have to work
together for the next two
months on this project.
How are we going to do that?
I know two people here and
the other seven I don't know.
How do we do that?
First of all, you
keep teams small.
I was talking with folks
in people dev this morning,
and average team size they
said is nine people here.
So that's good.
So single digit teams, much
better than super large teams.
We can actually have that
personal interaction.
I know your name.
I know something about you.
And then you've got
to actually share
a little bit outside just I'm
a Ruby on Rails programmer
and that's my goal in life.
Or I work in Go or whatever.
I need to actually know
something more about you.
So do you have a dog?
Do you have kids?
Do you have a wife?
We did this at meetings, right?
Do you know someone I know?
Oh, yeah.
I know Simon.
So do a little bit of sharing.
It's actually not wasted time.
Just like the 10 minute
pre-meeting meditation's
not a waste of time.
Get focused.
In that case, it's
focusing on being present.
I think the trust work is
really focusing on others.
It's not focusing so much on me.
Let's just focus on who you are.
What do you want
to get out of this?
What are your real goals?
What drives you crazy here?
What makes you super happy?
We could do that in 10 minutes.
Tell me one thing that's
really unusual that you
love about Google,
and tell me one thing
that drives you nuts here.
You guys all know that.
You don't have to share it
now, but you all know it.
So let me know about
you, because you're
a human, not a human resource.
So I think just changing
that language is a start.
Are there personality
differences?
For sure.
And we see in experiments
there are about 5%
of the population who
are super responders.
They increase oxytocin
levels with a social stimulus
five standard variations
above the mean.
And they're super
empathic, super warm.
Those people are always great.
They have tons of friends.
Everything works for them.
What I think you want to
do is bring in the people
who struggle a little bit.
Who maybe are more introverted.
Who don't like to leave
their offices much.
Say, let's go down
to the cafeteria.
Let's grab a coffee or
grab a beer after work.
Spend a little bit of investment
and get to know that person.
I think it's not that hard.
And you know my prescription
as Dr. Love is, of course,
eight hugs a day.
So it's OK.
You can hug people at work.
You won't get sued.
No creepy hugs.
Just say, look, I hug
everybody in my group.
I saw a lot of
people hugging today.
It's appropriate.
That's what the humans do.
You can build that relationship.
Or I'll go play some volleyball,
go play some ping pong.
Get to know that person
just a little bit.
You'd be surprised.
And also I have to say, also
celebrate the difficult people.
So there are
difficult people here.
There are difficult
people everywhere.
See them as an opportunity for
you to practice compassion,
for you to really show
you trust someone who's
hard to trust, who
just isn't as open.
That's a great way
to stretch yourself,
since we're all
interested in investment,
in growing a little bit.
Gives you a chance to grow.
SZYMON PERKOWSKI:
We're out of time.
PAUL ZAK: We're out of time.
Gosh.
SZYMON PERKOWSKI: But I wanted
to thank Paul once again
for coming here and speaking.
PAUL ZAK: And thank
you for listening.
[APPLAUSE]